these days people are paying more
attention to the source of things they
buy or even eat now we might apply that
same sensibility to objects in our
museums it turns out that all around the
world many items on display were stolen
from their original surroundings and the
people and cultures who Revere them CBS
News senior foreign correspondent
Elizabeth Palmer visited one celebrated
location for a first-hand look at the
problem
it was Hollywood that turned the temple
complex around Angkor Wat into an
ultra-famous movie location
[Music]
but it's so much more
a 900 year old Wonder of History
religion and art this made it a top stop
on countless bucket lists
it's also the site of an epic theft
thousands of people visit these ruins
every day and yet look closely at some
of the temples especially the Lesser
known ones and you'll notice that
something vital is missing
exquisitely carved stone statues of
Hindu gods and Buddhas and better
appreciation for American lawyer Brad
Gordon has made it his mission to track
them down many of these statues have
spiritual qualities and the cambodians
regard them as their ancestors they
believe that they're living
foreign
in the Decades of lawlessness following
cambodia's Civil War looters raided
these sites and made off with Priceless
artifacts
one of them was a local man talktick
codenamed lion before his death in 2021
he came clean and led Gordon and a team
of archaeologists to the sites that he'd
robbed he brought me to this Temple and
it was all covered with dirt one
Discovery was this pedestal and the
fragment of a foot
Lions said he'd stolen a statue from
here in 1997 and Gordon's research shows
it's this standing female deity
currently in New York's Metropolitan
Museum of Art we have his confirmation
and then we have a French archaeologist
who uses 3D imaging and he's been able
to match the body at the mat to the foot
that's here
looted Treasures have been trickling
back to Cambodia
in March a trove of them were returned
by a collector in the UK who'd inherited
them and decided this was the ethical
Choice some museums are actually
contacting us now and saying hey we
don't want to have stolen objects would
you review our collection if you want
any of them back please just tell us but
so far not the met the meta has been
very difficult
in spite of having returned to Cambodian
sculptures the kneeling attendance in
2013 so far the Met is not budging on
the standing female deity our request to
the museum for comment went unanswered
they have but Gordon isn't giving up if
it was illegal
can it not be fixed in the courts at the
moment we have been working with the U.S
government
providing them information on the
collection and the US government has
their own investigation going on if it
doesn't
work out to our satisfaction we are
confident that we can bring civil action
the goal ultimately is to restore piece
by piece at least some of the ancient
figures that once graced this famous
site
for CBS Saturday morning Elizabeth
Palmer Coker Cambodia